Turing was
um Alan Turing who was considered as the
father of modern Computing right so he
actually did something very similar so
he had a sculpting problem
that he proved that halting problem
cannot be solved algorithmically that
you cannot out of all computer programs
roughly speaking you could not you could
not you cannot have an algorithm of
choosing out of all can be possible
computer programs which ones are
meaningful which ones will not which
ones will halt very depressing results
all across the table
or on the contrary life affirming
depends on your point of view because
everything is full of paradoxes so that
means everything so you're right it's
depressing if we are sold on a certain
idea from the outset and then suddenly
this doesn't pan out
but okay so which my I report what if
what if he proved that actually
you know everything can be proved so
then what what is left to do if you're a
mathematician so that would be
depressing to me
and here there is an opportunity to do
something new to do to discover
something new which may be a computer
will not be able to again with the
caveat according to our current
understanding maybe some new technology
some new ideas will be brought into the
subject
and the meaning of the word computation
like now we think of condition in a
particular framework during machines or
church thesis and stuff like that but
what if in the future another Genius
Like Alan Turing will come and propose
something else the theory will evolve
the way you know we went from Newton's
gravity to Einstein's gravity maybe in
the framework of that concept some other
things will become possible
you know so
um it's not
to me it's kind of like
not so much about
deciding once and for all how it is or
how it should be
but kind of like accepting it as an
open-ended process I think that's much
more valuable in some sense than
deciding things one way or another you
know I wonder
I don't know if you think or know much
about cellular automata and the idea of
emergence
I I often return to Game of Life yeah
and just look at the thing amazing right
and wonder the kind of things they can
do with such a small
um you know tools that from Simple Rules
a distributed system can create complex
Behavior
and it makes you wonder that maybe the
thing we'll call computation
is simple at the base layer but when you
start looking at greater and greater
layers of abstraction you zoom out with
blurry vision maybe after a few drinks
you start to see some uh something
that's much much much more complicated
and interesting and beautiful than the
original rules
that are scientific intuition says
cannot possibly produce complexity and
Beauty I don't know I don't know if
anyone has a good answer a good model of
why
stuff emerges
why complexity emerges from a lot of
simple things
it's a why question I suppose another
but every why question will eventually
have a a rigorous answer not necessarily
I could have an approximate answer
which still eludes something like
quantum mechanics 99 maybe we will be
able to describe it
was 99 certainty or 99 accuracy yeah and
then maybe you know
in in 100 years or you know next year
somebody will come up with a different
point of view which suddenly will change
our perspective
you know to this point I want to say
also you know one thing that I find
fascinating speaking of paradoxes and so
on
do you remember how everybody was
freaking out about this blue dress
and the blue was it blue or was it black
yeah it was the yellow I think yellow or
and white or black and blue it almost
broke Twitter you know I remember that
yeah that night
so there are many examples like that
where you can perceive things
differently and there is no way of
saying which is correct which is not for
instance
uh you got this uh the bars the Rubens
bars you know where you have from one
perspective it's a verse from another
perspective it's two faces
then there is this dark rabbit picture
where you can Google it if somebody
doesn't know they can Google it and find
it it's very easy actually Ludwig
wittenstein devoted several Pages Duck
Rabbit in his book and so on there are
many others there are like squares where
you can square you can see the from
different perspective this way that's
why it's on
so when we talk about neural networks
we're talking about training
data and stuff and so that you have some
pictures for example that you feed to
your program
and you try to find the most optimal
neural network which would be able to
decide which one is it that the dog or
cat or whatever but sometimes it doesn't
have a definite answer
so what do you do then so
do actually it's a question I actually
don't know has modern AI even come to
appreciate this question that actually
sometimes you can have a picture on
which you cannot say what it is in it
from one perspective it's a rabbit from
an episode is a duck how are you
supposed to train if you have a neural
network which supposed to discriminate
between distinguish between ducks and
rabbits how is it going to process this
you see well so the the trivial trick it
does is to say there's a this x
probability that it's a duck and this
probability that it's a rabbit but
that's a good approach but also I would
say there's no like given percentages
for instance actually at some point I
was really curious about it and I looked
and for some for each picture of this
nature and there are a bunch of them you
can easily find online
my mind immediately interprets it in a
particular way but because I know that
other people have could see it
differently I would then strain my mind
and strain my eyes and stare at it and
try to see it in a different way and
sometimes I could see it right away and
then I could go back and forth between
the two and sometimes it could it took
me a while for some pictures
so in that sense even if this
probabilities exist they are subjective
some people immediately see it this way
some people may see that way and I think
that nobody knows not psychologists not
neuroscientists not philosophers what to
make of it
the best answer the of course as a
scientific mind I will I'm even though I
say no don't look for interpretation
leave some place for mysticism or
mystery right I say that but of course I
want a theory I want an explanation
so the best explanation I find is from
Niels Bohr's complementarity principle
so it is like particle and wave
that there are different ways to look at
it
and when you look at it in a particular
way another side will be obscured think
about it like the other side of the moon
you know so like we are observing the
Moon from one side and then we don't see
the other side there is a complementary
perspective where we see the other side
but not the side we normally see but the
Moon is the same you still there it's
our limitations of being able to grasp
the whole
that's complementarity and we know that
from quantum mechanics that our physical
reality is like that
rather than being certain rather than
being one way or another
and we should just as a smaller side
in terms of neural networks mentioned
that
at the end of the day there's humans is
built on top of humans or with Chad gbt
that it's using reinforcement learning
by human feedback
we're actually using a set of humans
to teach than our works yeah and that's
the thing that people don't often talk
about because
or I I sometimes think about that
those humans all have a life story each
human that annotated data that fed data
to the network or did the rlhf yeah uh
that they have a life story they grew up
they have biases so biases there's some
things that they like there's some
things they don't like which can kind of
appear under the Raider screen they may
not be aware that they are exercising
those biases that's the point what you
brought up is a very important issue
here not so it might issue but it's not
a bug it's a it's a feature in my
opinion that implicit in the discussion
of the question
is thinking computational and so on is
the idea that our conscious awareness
covers everything within our psyche and
we we just know that that's not the case
we have all of us have observed uh other
people who have had sort of destructive
Tendencies so obviously they did things
distracting for themselves and many of
us have observed ourselves to doing that
as part of human nature right so and
there is great research in analytic
psychology and you know in the past 100
years uh strongly suggesting if not
proving the existence of what Carl Jung
called the unconscious personal
unconscious and also Collective
unconscious this is a kind of a circle
of ideas which are under the radar
screen
which lead us to some strong emotions
and Inspire us to act in certain ways
even if we cannot really understand
so if we accept that then it the
preposition that somehow everything can
still be covered by our actions which
are totally
kind of neutral and totally like
righteous and totally
um conscious that it becomes really
tenuous